[Music]
in the movie the campaign you're playing
a politician right now not a
particularly talented in his own way but
not sure ethical politician yeah this is
not the first time you've played a
politician though for many years ago who
played George W Bush I played George W
Bush and yes did you ever meet him I'm
just curious I don't know if he's
flattered by that impression or not I
don't know if he is either never heard
from him it's too bad yeah but I know I
got to meet him once at SNL when he was
then he was then still governor and he
was running for president awning for
president and they made a big deal about
would you come down he's a huge fan he
really wants to meet you and I thought
okay okay and you get down to the studio
and their tons of you know the White
House press is all around him and the
campaign press any and they just go up
and say hello and so I'm like hi mr.
governor thanks so much is like pleased
to meet you and I can tell he has no
idea who I am
[Laughter]
is this a long week for you the shows a
hard work like I'm like yeah I think he
thought it was like a crew member
so I just said anyway nice to meet you
he was like yeah and I walked away and
then I think he added it up later that
oh he added it up by one experience well
we I want to make sure we get to this
this is a clip from the movie the
campaign this is a which I really like
there's a there's a moment here where is
this where you are drugged accidentally
I can't remember what else I I have I go
over to Zach's house right to kind of a
man we decide to try to have some civil
discord and we have a we have a few
Bourbons and and then as a dirty tactic
he calls the police on me right and this
is what happens let's take a look at
this clip from the campaign so have you
been drinking yes I have I've had five
or six small batch Bourbons that's a lot
I'm gonna have to ask you to take a
breathalyzer test
[Music]
that's not a wise move it's also funny
because you're so well known and that
you're famous in the context of the
movie and you're driving a car with your
name all over it it's not like you're
not gonna find stealing a cop car never
a good idea